so there's my working let's just have a
look at this because this is something
which we're going to encounter I promise
in many questions in the exercises and
in your assessments as well what if the
area that's between the two curves what
if that area crosses the x-axis now you
can see how poor all these warning signs
here right because we spent like a good
amount of time warning you that when you
integrate you get areas that are
negative or you get values that are
negative if the area is beneath the axis
so what we've been trying to do is train
you to be super cautious when you're
like oh there's an area beneath the axis
I should treat it like differently I
should you know take it separately and
deal with over here and then deal with
the rest of it positively right now if
you're looking at this and thinking oh
man like this is a mess right like if I
were to integrate how would I divide
this up into appropriate chunks well it
seems to me like you've got you've got
this section here this section here at
least that's all positive so I could
form an integral for that that would be
all right but then when you have a look
at this part underneath you're like okay
I can integrate let's see let's use a
different color I can integrate from
here to here for the red curve and I
just need to slap a minus sign on there
and then oh man like what on earth and
we're gonna have to do with this guy
over here like it's between both curves
but it's negative and like my brain
hurts okay so what do I do with this is
this going to be a real nightmare to try
and work with and the answer is no
mercifully and there's a really simple
reason why and I'm just going to show
that to you really quickly right now
let's just suppose I didn't want to deal
with this whole positive negative
business right I'm like that's gross
that hurts my brain what could I do here
to make this easier for me now there was
someone who I can't remember who was
mrs. Lee's maybe you have a better
memory than I do someone was having a
think about a problem over the last few
days where they said can we just
consider this as an area somewhere else
like can I move the graph up and down so
that I don't have to worry about
positives and negatives I don't have to
worry about going to the y-axis instead
of the x-axis now I can't remember who
did it someone might be able to put
their hand up in the chat and say it was
me I did that really smart thing I'm
gonna do a similar thing here and
use that trick okay so yeah was it you
max what is it hmm I thought it was
someone else
nice nice taking your credit since I
can't remember Beth anyway that's that's
fine what are we gonna do here right
let's just imagine this f of X and this
G of X if I took the same area and just
slid the whole thing upwards right if I
shift it far enough eventually the whole
thing is gonna be above the x-axis right
like I've got no scale here I don't know
how big or small these things are but if
I added like say I don't know maybe if I
added one that would you know move both
of them up a little bit maybe that
wouldn't be far enough maybe if I just
added a hundred to both of them that
would make it far enough a thousand
doesn't matter let's just suppose I move
both graphs and equal distance upwards
because they're moving together the area
that's enclosed between them will be
equivalent okay I guess if you wanna
think about a numerical example right if
I said you know what is 7 take away 3
well if I move both of those numbers up
by a hundred well a hundred and seven
take away a hundred and three the
difference between them is the same so I
can use this technique if if it's
helpful to me okay now watch what
happens if I try this out okay with this
particular one you remember I've got to
work out the top take away the bottom
top take away bottom so in this case
this is the function on the top so I'm
going to say my area equals I'm gonna
integrate from some place to some other
place again some start point to some end
point okay
and I'm gonna do the top function which
is the blue one with respect to X and
then I'm going to subtract the bottom
function which is my red one okay so
again it's from the same start to the
same end and this function has also been
raised up 100 units so it's it's also
gone up okay all right now what happens
when I try and simplify this thing well
just like before I'm gonna try and
reduce these multiple integrals into a
single integral right so because I
notice again my boundaries are the same
from A to B I can just take the two
integrals which are these
two things here things being integrated
in here and I can just do a straight
subtraction so I'm gonna get let's see
here G of X plus a hundred and then I'm
going to subtract everything that I saw
in the red integral which is I'm gonna
I've got an f of X and I've also got a
100 but I'm gonna subtract that right
now hopefully at this point you can see
what's happening even though I had to
add a hundred to both and to move them
both up into positive territory you can
see that I've got this plus 100 and this
minus 100 so they're exactly cancelling
now Abby you've asked the question why
is G the top function have a look
closely
which one is above and which one is
below it's hard to see with the colors
because the shading kind of takes over
but the the blue function here which is
G of X it goes over the top you see that
it's the one going over the top like so
well I missed you get the idea okay and
that red function underneath which I see
mrs. Lee's has already typed about
here's the red function underneath it's
clearly on the bottom of the green graph
okay so blue takeaway red top takeaway
bottom you've just got to be careful for
which one is which okay now let's finish
out this working and we're gonna see
thankfully if this means that it doesn't
matter too much whether my area crosses
the x-axis my integral is from A to B my
100's are just gonna cancel out so let's
go
bang-bang and what I get left with is G
of X take away f of X which is the same
top takeaway bottom that we saw before
it almost doesn't matter whether the
area is above the x axis or beneath the
x axis there are gonna be negatives but
they all kind of cancel out in the wash
as I've just demonstrated here okay
so therefore what's our conclusion it's
still top takeaway bottom wherever the
area happens oh that's a funny ammonia
in there wherever the area happens to be
even if it's beneath the axis top
takeaway bottom will get you there and
one of the the weird things about that
is if both of your graphs if like if
your entire area is beneath the axis
like something like this here we go if
your area let's use a color because I've
got color
if your entire area is underneath here
when you're doing top takeaway bottom
because you're doing a negative take
away another negative it ends up
positive so the area between two curves
so long as you top take away bottom are
you sick of me saying that yeah so long
as you get the order right you will
always get a positive area okay so I
used an example of a hundred there
because just to illustrate I'll just
take it up as far as you need to to make
it all positive but if or a thousand or
if were one whatever you like it will
always cancel since you're moving both
functions the same distance okay all
right so I'm gonna take a breath there
let's just make sure we get this all
together when you are dealing with the
area between two curves you're going to
work out the areas just like you did
before but you'll do a subtraction top
takeaway bottom even if the area you're
dealing with crosses the x-axis so some
was positive and some negative top
takeaway bottom will still make sure
that you get all the right answers
because everything will sort of cancel
out in the wash as it were so you're now
ready to progress with the rest of
exercise 1f we started on that yesterday
max you gave a big shout so that you
could say oh it's a short exercise
that's great well now we're giving you
the rest of it so I'm showing you here
these are the questions in exercise 1f
that I'd like you to continue working on
and we did 3 & 4 right there in the
middle but now you can come back to 1 2
6 9 and 11 now when you keep on going
some of those later questions will
become more complicated because what
will happen is and I'm just going to
draw your quick and dirty example rather
than having a graph where it's nice and
neat and for example you've got
something like this and when you're
working at that area between the two
curves there's only a single area okay
so it's like oh I just need to find out
where it starts and where it ends you're
gonna encounter problems where the graph
is much messier so you might have
something like let me get rid of this
guy you might have something like this
and because you've got more areas here
you're gonna have to deal with this guy
over here
and this guy over here
and you you are gonna have to deal with
them somewhat separately okay so as you
can see that's much more complicated I
want you to go ahead and take some time
on your own to watch the video that says
areas between hours I say I think Eric
functions that cross multiple times what
functions with multiple crossings I
think is what I called it okay so you
can go ahead there's a couple of worked
examples in there